welcome to Horace holidays the channel
where we discussed the latest tech news
and delve into the newest tech products
today we're taking a look at how the gtx
1180 will actually be better than two
gtx ten eighties in sli but before we
delve into that make sure to hit that
subscribe button if you guys like to
stay updated with the latest tech news
related to gaming and pcs so recently
there have been a lot of rumors and
leaks surrounding the release date of
the gtx 1180 and there has been a lot of
debate over when the gtx 1180 is
actually going to come out but what a
lot of these rumors and leaks don't
cover is the performance of the gtx of
and if the performance of the gtx 1180
isn't good that nothing else is even
relevant in the first place so to
determine the performance of the gtx
1180 we should first look at the leaked
specs of the gtx 1180 so starting off
the gtx 1180 is supposed to have 3584
cuda cores and 224 TM use just like the
gtx 980ti
but that's pretty much where the
similarities end the gtx 1180
will have higher core clocks with a base
frequency of 1600 megahertz and the max
boost frequency of 1800 megahertz
additionally the gtx 1180 will also have
a smaller die size of 400 millimeters
squared instead of 471 millimeters
squared found on the gtx 980ti
on top of this the gtx 1180 will have 8
gigabytes of gddr3 beyond the 20 meter
process be based on GT 104 and it will
accomplish all this while consuming less
power than the gtx 980ti with an
estimated TDP of 170 to 200 watts so in
essence the gtx at 1180 will have the
same raw horsepower as the gtx 980ti
while being more efficient and having
some upgrades like GTD or 6 memory and
the new architecture furthermore the gtx
1180 may also have a technological
advantage over the gtx 1080i because the
gtx 1180
may support ray-tracing and come with
tenser course i don't believe the gtx
1180 will come in tens of course that
may just be reserved for the gtx 1180 TI
but i do believe that the gtx 1180 or
most like
they support ray-tracing technology
according to gamer mode the GTX 1180 is
supposed to support DirectX 12.5 and
DirectX 13 and raised tracing technology
maybe what that is all about also
without this the gtx 1180 would just be
an incremental upgrade but if it does
have ray tracing then it'll be a huge
leap forward and I think NVIDIA would
prefer that because it's a huge
marketing point and it would really
separate the GTX and 1100 series from
attempt series and it would really
motivate buyers to go and upgrade to the
GTX 11 her series even if it happened 10
series already so it would lead to a
significant increase in sales as a
result the 12 nanometer process GDRs six
memory the new architecture and possible
ray tracing technology would all work
together and give the gtas 1180 a
sizable upgrade over the GTX 1080i the
GTX 10 atti
was already very comparable with 2/10
80s in SLI and in many times the GTX 10
ADT I would actually beat out the 10 a
DS in SLI in terms of frames per second
taking that into consideration the GTX
1180 should perform better than 2/10 80s
in SLI across the board as a result we
should see a solid 60 plus frames per
second for all modern games at 4k with
the gtx 1180 also the 1180 should crush
triple monitor in gaming 1440p ultra
wide gaming and pretty much any gaming
style you prefer and as a result the GTX
1180 will indeed be a gaming monster so
that's all cool enough but what about
the price at the GTX lm-80
because that is one of the most
important things to consider when
deciding to buy a new GPU well according
to gamer mode a third-party variant of
the GTX 1180 is going to come out for an
MSRP of 720 dollars based off that and
considering that usually third-party
parents are more expensive because they
usually have better cooling and also
have hired clocks the founder Edition
should come at a lower price of probably
$700 while this may seem expensive it's
actually not that bad considering that
the GTX 1080 also came out for an MSRP
of $700
and you're pretty much getting to ten
eighties with the 1184 pretty much the
same price I know that SLI doesn't scale
well but what I'm trying to say is that
just two years ago you would have to
spend $1400 to get the same performance
the GTX at 1180 will offer you and now
you can get it for $700 so that's
definitely really good progress
finally when exactly is this new gtx
1180 going to come out
well according to gamer meld the gtx
1180 should come out on July 30th but
considering that we haven't heard
anything from Nvidia and considering
that they have a lot of excess 10
serious GPUs in in their inventory I
don't think this is going to happen what
I think is more likely is a reveal at
hot chips conference in August and a
release in September so should you wait
for the GTX at 1180 well in my opinion
definitely if you're considering the gtx
980ti because it's going to cost the
same amount and you'll get a pretty good
performance upgrade in my opinion the
best thing to do if you were in that
situation is wait for the holiday season
of this year and pick up a brand new gtx
1180 at a really good discount like for
650 or $16 during Black Friday or Cyber
Monday but that's just what I think what
do you guys think are you guys really
hyped for the gtx 1180 and when do you
guys think it's going to come out make
sure to comment down below what you guys
think because I do read all my comments
and I'm curious as to what you guys
think so make sure to post your thoughts
also if you guys like this video then
make sure drop a like and hit that
subscribe button if you guys like to see
more videos just like this one but until
next time bye
[Music]